stop
oh no
[Music]
[Laughter]
what
it's that dark Trooper music
oh that's right
oh he's got the horns on the helmet
that's interesting it's Darth Maul
oh my God could you imagine okay okay
Giancarlo Esposito
thank you for Gathering the mandalorians
into one place
what okay I will create an army
that will bring order to the Galaxy wow
okay his plan explained welcome back to
New rockstars the Mandalorian chapter 23
reveals a shadow Council of Imperial
warlord setting up the first order with
things like project neck bromancer
awaiting the return of thrawn oh no and
this leads to our dear friend possibisla
died at the hands of some praetorian
guards The Last Jedi but it's a silent
partner the real spy of this episode the
armor uh so we have questions we would
have questions if so but dank ferric
this episode this episode actor dank
ferric indeed Eric I can't believe
you're bringing this up because that
would make me so so sad if it was the
armorer I love her I love her very much
we did suspect something that was up
with a head with the armor earlier this
season but it wasn't this right it was
something else anyway welcome back to
the break room presents Wikileaks our
weekly Mandalorian for show I'm Eric
Voss Tommy Tech builds out this week but
I'm here with Hector Navarro hey
everybody so happy to be here I'm gonna
try to do my best to fill in that Tommy
energy
and like so Hector just like opening
opening look at this episode what are
your thoughts coming out of this very
dense very very dense this is the one
that was like okay y'all don't like
having fun with Jack Black and lizzo
fine here's the lore here's all of the
setup for the next couple of years of
Star Wars storytelling yeah I know from
the beginning of the series that they
were gonna say this is going to show us
the rise of the first order so they're
delivering on those promises I I have no
problem all that all that being set up
but I love the idea that they're
bringing in like thrawn minions in this
uh in this midst in this conspiracy I'm
dying to know who the spies of this
episode were because you know it's
called the spies and on the surface
everyone is kind of just like being
exactly who they say they were no one's
being duplicitous but it also seems like
the mandalorians got set up on this
planet a little bit so I'm trying to
reconcile my feelings between those two
things if there were spies who set them
up there's just a lot of like logic gaps
on how they did that or why they would
want to to do that or how that fits them
with other things that they've done in
the past yeah so I'm excited to talk
through this episode with you Hector so
what the fet happened in this episode
things really start cooking here in
episode 7 the spies Elia Kane meets up
with a hologram of moff Gideon in a back
alley of Coruscant to discuss the status
of their plan she reveals to him that
things aren't going great on Navarro
best planet in Star Wars Galaxy as the
mandalorians are working together to
fend off pirate attacks we then see moth
Gideon address the shadow Council
coolest name we've heard in Star Wars in
a long time there are many interesting
characters there including brendel hux
who is played by Brian Gleason the
brother of General hux's Domo Gleason
the shadow of the family that was really
cool awesome I thought it was fantastic
uh really really happy to see that if
you're a hux fan and I am I think that
character is hysterical
um the shadow council is in in disarray
as they await the return of grand
Admiral thrawn I I think that they're
giving us like putting faces and names
to who exactly is behind this conspiracy
so it kind of makes it clear I mean we
we could guess we know from the phasma
books that you know the hux family was
was there and was part of this we know
that snoke was being like puppeted by
Palpatine but that seemed to be like the
kind of uh the dark side angle as
opposed to like the political
bureaucratic uh functioning behind it so
that's what we're seeing now
um I I like that they call themselves
The Shadow Council because it's there's
really no debate anymore over whether or
not we're the baddies like they know but
it's also been like true to Star Wars
since the beginning of the Shadow
collected we've had everyone like yeah
we know we're evil we don't care it
makes me hope that someday the MCU will
get the masters of evil because it's
just like the best team villain name
the the Brotherhood of evil mutants as
Magneto once called them it's great
um so then moth Gideon convinces the
council to send him Aid so he can
destroy the mandalorians once and for
all speaking of mandalorians the night
owls and the remnants of the death watch
are reunited on Navarro for a grand
feast and before the feast grief karga
presents din jarn with a rebuilt ig-11
now ig-12 a grogu pilotable version of
the old Droid with the vocal functions
to say yes and no Eric did you like this
element in the episode because my answer
is yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes
yes yes yes yes
I I need a sometimes button sometimes
sometimes sometimes sometimes we're just
like a mix of yes and no because I mean
anything that you give grogu to do
especially this little like Bjorn visual
of him just sitting in the chest
operating it getting to grab milarune
Roots I'm okay with all that stuff I
think it's so fun and it's a delight but
it's like did we have to do this to ig11
there like his corpse is being mutilated
and desecrated hey in return they
lobotomized him like why not just let
him live as a statue Jesus Christ
because rogo needed a Mech to Pilot and
uh you know we may still get a reversion
back to the ig-11 because where did we
leave off it was just like we're missing
one piece one Droid piece that the end
Zealand could still maybe put into ig-12
to make a my G11 isn't that where we
left according to palimoto that part
isn't made anymore it doesn't exist I'm
sorry you got to get that they don't
make that charger anymore you gotta buy
the new one that's such a bummer and a
little too close to home so at the feast
bocatan rallies the troops to retake
Mandalore and a small Team Heads to the
surface of the battle scarred Planet
while the remaining mandalorians remain
in orbit just above Mandalore on the
surface they meet a surviving group of
mandalorians who never left their
Homeworld very Mad Max they agreed to
take Beau and Company to the great Forge
ax woe and pause Vizsla continue a great
tradition of physically fighting over a
board game but the fight is broken up by
grogu in his ig-12 suit again love this
moment thought it was fantastic very
fitting for grogu and his I guess
character development I did like that a
lot I I mean that it seems like if the
whole reason was to just be able to have
grogu physically separate these two
Warrior mandalorians then I think it's
totally worth it yeah could the child
have just used the force to repel the
two probably he did hold back a mud horn
and tame the rancor yeah but that's true
you gotta imagine that of them those
Bandos are probably smaller than those
huge creatures that you just mentioned
but you know Hasbro's got to sell new
action figures and I for one can't wait
for the ig-12 with the little grogu
accessory in the chest it's gonna be
great so then the group is attacked by a
giant creature not the mythosaur but
they managed to survive and head
underground where they are once again
attacked but this time by Gideon's Mando
inspired Troopers who the heck are all
these guys I I don't like them boo to
them I've yeah have questions they are
clearly design wise being set up to look
like the first order Stormtroopers I
think they have like the same kind of
shaped chess pieces and everything uh
but yeah like what from whom is he
recruiting them it sounds like there's
like a faction of Imperial loyalists
everywhere there was that line among the
shadow Council where it's like that you
know they're still eager eager to fight
but it's just like man that they were
all able to do this in secret on
Mandalore it's just I brings up a lot of
questions yeah absolutely I mean we are
how many years removed from The Purge
like like the Empire or the remnants I
guess at this point knew that it wasn't
so poisonous and toxic that they could
go and build all that base out it's very
very impressive but like you said
there's there's loyalists to the Empire
everywhere it's just a bunch of Elia
Keynes basically like in this armor
flying around but thankfully I think the
mandalorians are a little bit more
skilled in that kind of battle but but
they do get pinned down in a trap set by
Gideon din is captured and Beau and the
rest of the mandalorians are able to
retreat say for rip pause Vizsla who
heroically sacrifices himself to buy
more time for the rest of the group to
escape he takes out a dozen or so
Troopers before being killed by
praetorian guards and that's what you
missed on Glee I mean the Mandalorian
season three okay sorry
ah what what a heartbreaker in the
episode just a smash cut to black I mean
I know they showed us heavy repeating
Blaster just heating up in his hands
he's like he spent it all the way down
to the last charge ah
it hurts to see this guy go down listen
it's Star Wars at its best Eric I don't
know if you have been caught up on the
bad batch but um we had some some pretty
emotional finale action going on over
there for the bad batch season two and
like we've been saying a lot of the the
story and plot elements are really kind
of tying into what they're exploring
into Mandalorian but it was just a real
one-two punch this past week of like the
bad batch season finale
and now this no pause Vizsla R.I.P it's
so so sad but I've Loved this sort of
character development again I think it's
the best that Star Wars can offer where
they take a cool looking character in
the background who you don't know that
much about and over time little by
little you learn more about the
character you start to like the
character all of a sudden your ride or
die with this character like this dude
is awesome when he went to defend DIN
and started a speech with like basically
saying this is a bunch of but
didn't save my son's life and now I'm
gonna stand by him no matter what like
immediately endearing it's so much fun
um and what a great heroic sacrifice
this is the way indeed ah I thought it
was I thought it was fantastic and some
great physical work by Tate Fletcher
absolutely got it he was absolutely
incredible to watch I totally agree I
really hope that uh like a lot of great
sci-fi television that Tate is still a
part of the show and can just play
another faceless character who we
haven't maybe met yet because that
physicality that acting that performance
that voice it's all fantastic so huge
props to uh to take yeah we saw him in
the pilot episode in that bar on the ice
Planet like with this face but he could
play any other character just do not let
him like he has to have that that white
mustache yeah yeah
non-negotiable he will not lose that
mustache nor should he ever just a quick
reminder that the best way to support
new rockstars is to grab some merch From
Nerd riot.shop we have a a amazing uh
assortment of Mandalorian inspired
shirts and hoodies and all this great
stuff you can get this like grogu one uh
so yeah grab all that at nerd riot.shop
and thank you for supporting us uh and
Hector so let's talk a bit more about
the shadow Council and this question of
is the armorer a spy like to quote
another famous hux am I the spot you
know
[Laughter]
um because yeah we meet uh part of the
Shadow Council obviously includes moff
Gideon
um but we have brindle hux who as you
mentioned Brian Gleason brother to
Donald Gleason brindle is the father to
Armitage hux Domino Gleason's character
in the sequel Trilogy yeah and really it
is this father and son that oversee the
creation of you know what they call the
perfect soldier in the early years of
the first order a lot of this is covered
in the phasma book so go back and read
the phasma book you find out her history
with these armitages and uh these are
these huxes but with the armintages and
the brindles and the Stokes and all of
them uh it's a very interesting read it
gives you a lot of context here actually
and spoiler warning for you know this
book at least this is what happens in
the book we don't know how strict
they're going to stick to it but you
know brindle is killed by his son
Armitage Armitage takes over he commits
patricide and that's how Armitage hux
becomes a major leader in the first
order now this episode is called the
spies and you know we would be remiss to
uh if we didn't mention that wonderful
moment in the rise of Skywalker where
Armitage hux revealed himself to be a
spy but I don't think the huxes here are
the spies it's also established that
brindle is overseeing what is called
project Necromancer and necromancy is
the occult art of resurrecting dead
bodies and just you know fiddling with
dead bodies see what you learned
apparently this is the code name given
to the Sith eternals plot to clone and
resurrect Palpatine I might have been
wrong Hector but didn't look like moth
Gideon was walking past some tanks that
and contained something oh absolutely oh
100 yeah it seemed like there were more
it's just it's kind of just interesting
kind of they just have stars of like
past experiments everywhere they're like
okay these didn't work out but we'll
just keep these tanks here just in case
this yeast grows into something and we
don't want to throw it out very you
never know you get very very smart of
them to hold on to that you know it it
could lead to some delicious bread but
it's also very like Nazi experiment of
them very Nazi Eugenics you know to have
all of these anytime we see like
fictional Nazi storytelling there's
they're always performing these occult
experiments and they're always dabbling
with cloning and resurrecting zombies
and all this kind of stuff so and also I
hate to correct you on your own show
Eric I'm so so sorry but you keep saying
hux I believe the pronunciation is hugs
it's General hugs am I wrong I thought
it was hugs or maybe I'm just going off
of what Poe Dameron called him at the
beginning of the Last Jedi my favorite
my favorite favorite I'll hold for
General hugs can you hear me you know
what do not try to hug a a Gleason as we
saw in the band season he doesn't want
to hug he will cut off his fingers
of them oh my gosh um so I thought it
was interesting I'm off getting called
brindle hooks obsessed with creating
clones like this isn't just something
he's doing because some Sith occultist
was like Hey you have to do this because
Palpatine he's like no he wants he's all
about cloning he loves it so you have
both like a Sith cult that is doing the
cloning and you have like a military
faction who's into it as well and
Hudson's even asking he's like so did
you hear back from Dr Pershing because I
would love his research like he's so
into it it's like his favorite thing did
he mention me did he talk about me Dr
Pershing did he say anything how is he
oh I love him but we also learned that
hux already has praetorian guards we
know those Red Cloak badasses that
protected snoke on The Last Jedi so
happy we get to see these guys again and
now we also meet another interesting
figure Captain
glad pellion who's played by Xander
Berkeley a character actor who has been
in everything Gregory from The Walking
Dead he played the foster dad in
Terminator 2. he was like the the Spy AI
secret service agent on Air Force One I
think one of my favorite roles of his
he's so good in that this guy is a major
figure from Legends materials he first
appeared in heir to the Empire Timothy
zahn's thrawn book He's considered
thrawn's Protege he's uh just a
fascinating figure and he did Cameo
briefly in just through his voice in an
episode of rebels but otherwise that was
it so now we get to see him in live
action it's just that mustache the
hunched over appearance he looks exactly
as his captain would based off of what
you've read about him it's it's awesome
I just you know I I I've already been
having this discussion with my friends
over the past few years but it keeps
happening with every new episode of the
Mandalorian every new sort of
announcement but I I just can't believe
we're in a world where some of that old
great Legends material like the
character of grand Admiral thrawn is now
being really embraced by the rest of
Star Wars and put in not just in an
animated show but now a live action
series and is probably gonna appear in a
movie and I know that there are Star
Wars fans who who were upset when dizzy
he came out in 2015 and they're like
well we have to we have to do away with
this Canon because it doesn't really
line up with what we're trying to do but
I'm also hugely appreciative uh first of
all all that stuff is like still in
print like they're they just still want
to get your money any way they can so
you can get those books you can buy
those books they're at Barnes Noble
which is crazy
um but also just that everything that
they've been producing since then with
the expanded universe of novels and
comics and video games and VR
experiences like the lucasfilm
storytelling creative side you know
they're looking at what they're doing
with publishing with the high Republic
and instead of just going yeah you guys
can do whatever you want they're really
we're going to make a show set in that
era we're gonna use these characters and
use these great moments from the comics
and the novels and try to like you keep
mentioning phasma and I feel like
they're not going to contradict any of
that stuff but if there's an opportunity
they'll Embrace some of it they'll
reinforce some of it and it just it's so
so exciting that fans of extra material
and extra ways to enjoy this media like
novels and like comic books are not
um missing out but instead there it it's
just kind of like continues to reinforce
our love because it's like you guys are
in on something cool and it's so cool in
fact that the movies and the TV shows
are going to explore that same kind of
thing too it's just so so cool so so
exciting yeah and it makes it like clear
that at some point either on this show
or maybe in the the baloney director
movie we might see phasma too like she
was definitely around going forward at
this point in history yeah as the first
order Rises but they're all talking
about thrawn uh and Gideon specifically
seems doubtful that thrawn is even alive
anymore he calls out pellion on thrawn
being a nobody a no-show in these
meetings so I think that's setting up an
interesting conflict between Gideon and
thrawn we'll talk about that more later
now to talk about
the spies of this episode there's a lot
of questions over who the spies are and
you know my snap reaction coming out of
the episode is that the armor just seems
really suss this episode yeah and you
know you were there when we react to
episode 2 and I mentioned that that the
armor might be the big bad of the Season
my prediction there wasn't so much that
she would be a deceitful spy a political
tactician working with moth Gideon the
person who's done more damage to the
mandalorians than anyone to bring down
certain parts of the Mandalorian culture
or through some other kind of like
aspect of her character we don't know
about I thought her rigid stubborn super
Superstition and dogmatism would be what
would make her kind of a villain that it
would be a war between traditionalism
right and progressivism within the
Mandalorian tribes so this is certainly
a surprise to me but you know there are
certainly questions we have so the way
this episode ends with the armorer
working with these injured people to
take them back up to the light Cruiser
right we keep cutting back to her which
is so weird like didn't you feel like
she was either gonna just get shot yeah
like At first I saw her approach I
thought the light Cruiser just gonna get
nuked for a second that's what I thought
too I mean is there a possibility Eric
because I want to keep I want to keep
living in the world where the armorer is
good where the Armor gets to keep being
on the side of the mandalorians uh even
with her very extremist kind of cult-ish
way of thinking you're not wrong that
that's definitely a great source of
conflict but I really like her and I'm
hoping that that she's not full on the
Imperial Remnant loyalist or whatever
but is there a possibility that
continuing to cut back to that because I
was thinking oh
this is where Gideon and his crew are
going to show up and they're going to
take them all out was that a red herring
to make us think oh that's where they're
going to show up that's where they're
going to show up so then when we get to
further in the cave and all of a sudden
that's where the Trap lies it was just a
surprise pulling out the rug out from
under us of like no Gideon's been here
the whole time on Mandalore could that
be a possibility very possible very
possible
um we just have other questions like how
was he there like how did din jarin not
see this when they were at like we
visited Mandalore twice this season when
ninja and went there first and then like
were they just really quiet it's a
planet it's the planets are bigger than
one small community underground it's a
whole planet
okay okay you could land in Paris and
not know anything about what's going on
in Los Angeles so imagine Mandalore
there could be a whole system of caves
we have no idea what's going on that's
completely true completely true there
are multiple cities but I think it's
also fair to say Star Wars does not
treat planets like planets I'm like
you're right there's there's like two
cities on Tatooine and we've been to
them a lot the planet of Navarro is
basically just a town with no that's not
true because we've seen other parts in
Navarro There Was An Imperial base on
Navarro but it was also like a place off
the map that no one ever really talked
about so I think even the people living
in Navarro didn't think about what
happened and that Imperial base was just
on the outskirts of the capital city of
Navarro you're not wrong well and there
was an imperial presence there too
cinevar is not the best example I think
in fact a lot of this is good arguments
against uh against the armor being some
kind of villain because why would she
send why would she send uh Mando and
Boca time to or at least Bando to The
Living Waters because she would you know
in that case she would definitely risk
him stumbling upon the Imperial presence
when would she have had time to forge
together some best car armor for moff
Gideon if she was with you know Paz
visla and other members of the children
of the watch all that time like and it
didn't seem like they had ships yeah
until Bogota got there listen I just
want to also recall something I just
thought of right now going back to one
of the biggest betrayals in the entire
history of the Star Wars Galaxy order
66. the Clones were like good dudes and
one flip of the switch and all of a
sudden like a programming went off in
their head and they're like okay we have
to kill all the Jedi the people that
we've been working with all of these
generals that we respect immensely we
got to kill them all Jedi are bad so
what if the armor is this deep deep deep
undercover like secretive agent who is
basically placed here by Gideon years
ago with the caveat of like no just be a
Mandalorian be strong in your beliefs we
are going to give you a vague background
so people understand where you could
kind of you know infiltrate and be part
of the group but just continue to be
your true authentic self until I'm gonna
need to flip the switch say the code
word Winter Soldier you and all of a
sudden homecoming some of those other
code words and then she kind of goes
into like okay now I have to put all the
mandalorians in one place so that they
can all get taken out and I have to you
know listen to my programming yeah
doesn't that sound like a little
surprising with the fact that like the
mandalorians were already beaten you
know why would he need to set up
anything in a group of people that they
already completely wiped out after the
night of a thousand Tears In The Purge
like even the other members of The
Shadow Council were like mandalorians
they're still things like yeah yeah I I
guess we just have questions of how they
were set up like you know a lot of
people are saying just maybe ax woes is
the Spy but like if you were to go back
and look at all of his decisions it
doesn't really make sense for him to be
a spy either I think the issue is is
that we're looking at this as if it's a
show like Andor and it's not right it's
a show like the Mandalorian Clone Wars
yep it's for kids it's it you know it
can't be yeah it can't be complex enough
complicated enough that kids are gonna
sort of like lose the thread it's got to
be there's gonna be twists and turns but
it's gonna be things that like if you
sit down and really think about it
you're probably gonna be able to figure
it out because eight-year-olds have to
be able to be like oh whoa cool and
understand and follow sort of what's
happening I also want to point out too
could this title episode refer to Elia
Kane who really was in this episode
confirmed in what we've been suspecting
for many many episodes in this whole
season but she was revealed to be the
Spy working for Gideon could that be
with it but didn't we already know that
I'm sorry if I'm pressing you Hector
like it's so weird to call this episode
the spies Z plural yeah spies is it the
because the shadow Council are not spies
they're all clearly evil they're not
playing any any other kind of role right
right uh it's like suggesting that
there's someone within the Mandalorian
ranks that are spies yeah uh are those
pirates that they ran across spies I
don't think so I do have questions about
how they were able to survive but they
also seem to be like that rugged
survival list yeah Mad Max very Mad Max
listen all signs point to the armorer
but I just don't like it Eric that's all
I'm saying I just don't like it I yeah
I'm I'm with you Hector I I it just
brings up too many questions of like the
armorer's arc over these three seasons
that if she were a spy the whole time it
just is like well why did you hang out
in a cave that long when did you get
away what role what are you trying to
gain from this
um and I think that there's nothing to
gain for a Mandalorian who were
basically close to extinction from for
being a spy
um the only thing that I could see I
guess there's a question of timeline
like we look at these events throughout
season three as having happened within
like you know a couple months but if
they took place over like a year if like
what changes when when bocaton got back
from the Living Waters and said that
there's amid the Tsar under there that
could have been where things changed and
then like communication was sent to moff
Gideon like hey this is actually a
valuable place to be uh maybe now you
can set up your base there but I just
don't know when or how the armor could
have done that and it's also I you know
maybe the um the scene in this episode
code where bocatan actually explains the
deal that she made with Gideon in an
effort to protect whoa and spare her
people maybe that's a little bit of
foreshadowing and maybe the armor has a
similar deal set up that we're not privy
to yet that we you know in the next
episode if it is the armor I'm sure
we're gonna get the sort of like
explanation the villain speech you know
Gideon probably talking to din John with
the classic We're Not So Different you
and I and some sort of a revelation that
like the deal set up with the armorer
the Spy is that when she brings all of
the mandalorians together her specific
covert will be spared they will be able
to continue to live their life and their
way of thinking whereas bocatan and all
the rest of the forces but of course
Gideon is lying to her you know what I
mean we might get one of those classic
switcheroos where Gideon's like oh yeah
yeah sure sure
I told you that that your covert would
get what was owed to them and what was
owed to them was death and then he's
going to betray the armor and then the
armor will be like oh no why did I trust
this Imperial Imperium and now I've
decided to turn it back on him and maybe
I'll say
I'll suck off in an effort to uh to
redeem myself and it'll be that kind of
classic story but there may be just a
deal in place with the armor that we're
not aware of and that might be because
she is so loyal to her to her covert
that she was willing to play the card of
no Boca 10 you are accepted we embrace
you you can take off your helmet you
walk both worlds meanwhile on the inside
she's stewing she hates taking off your
helmet but she's like I'll play this
I'll play this role until I can position
you and your group in the night owls and
then you get killed off by Mach Gideon
so maybe the next episode maybe Ahsoka
maybe the next season of the Mandalorian
might reveal things that we don't know
yet but
fingers crossed that the armor can still
be good I like Emily swallow I like her
very much I do too and and for anyone
who's like it would be impossible for
the armor to be the villain I'm not
saying I want the armorer to be the
villain this way in fact I'm I think I'm
going to be a little confused still I'm
gonna have a lot of questions I'm just
saying we've covered these Disney Plus
shows for a long time and if you assume
they all have airtight logic with their
with their character motivations and the
reveals you're setting yourself up for
disappointment my friend they've done
some crazy before these shows that
do not make sense I mean Sharon broker
being the power broker or Sharon Carter
being the power broker doesn't really
make a lot of sense but they didn't you
know like they do this all the time and
then they decide until secret Invasion
when she gets revealed when she gets her
field to be a scroll Eric that's all
yeah I think I've just learned by being
burned in the past you can't have like
ultimate high expectations for all of
these shows I think you can kind of see
the writing on the wall with them with a
show like Andor you know that like they
put a lot of thought specifically into
character motivations that every
character feels like their protagonist
the protagonist of the story and
everything they do is uh pretty clear
according to their character's logic
um and based off of decisions they've
made in the past on these shows it's
really just like looked at more as a
top-down sort of thing where does this
character need to be to be with this
character to set up this spin-off and to
sell toys and I love those toys uh so
I'm alone for the rest and I will buy
all of those toys and I will watch all
the spin-offs I don't care she's
um but I want to ask you Hector about
this Brewing conflict between thrawn and
Gideon do you think the season ends with
thrawn killing Gideon oh you know I
thought about that while watching the
episode and I ultimately came back to
Giancarlo Esposito is too good of a draw
to not want to put him in a theatrical
New Republic experience now will Grand
Admiral thrawn kill moth Gideon in that
movie to show audiences like no thrawn's
like a real threat he just killed Gus
from bake from Breaking Bad like this
guy's a big deal yes I think that that
might happen there but I don't think
we're going to lose Giancarlo at the end
of this season I don't think we would
lose Giancarlo during the Ahsoka show I
don't think we're going to lose John
Carlo in the Mandalorian season four but
I think that in the sort of um Dave
filoni John Favreau Avengers end game
finale that they're building to I think
that's the kind of thing that you can
that you can wait for that it's almost
like a uh I don't know it's almost like
a um like a Vader versus Palpatine kind
of a of a thing and I think that that
for General audiences who might not know
especially movie audiences who might not
have seen every episode of Disney plus
TV shows or have watched Rebels or even
read any of the thrawn novels whether
New Canon or legends that kind of thing
is a great movie moment that really gets
audiences to oh snap this Grand Admiral
Throne is he's a big deal so that's my
prediction I don't think we're gonna
lose Giancarlo but I do think exactly
what you said will happen later nice any
other final predictions headed into the
finale Hector yes we're all gonna recoup
at uh plazier 15 we're gonna re we're
going to recruit Jack black lizzo
they're going to come in guns ablazing
to save dingarin and it's gonna be epic
yeah I'm trying to uh lock in I think we
will see thrawn in a post-credit scene I
agree but we might guess I don't think
he's gonna factor into the episode but I
think just structurally makes the most
sense to show that beautiful Lars
Mickelson face in a post-credits scene I
think it's gonna set up an interesting
period of time where I don't know if
thrawn's going to be serving the agenda
of the first order and I kind of like
that I want thrawn to be more of a rogue
I think we're going to suggest that he
is breaking away from the first order
and and I think that's the best move for
Star Wars as well I think you can
totally have part of the timeline
continue on you have the the hux Father
and Son operation that are that are
working with people like Gideon and the
rest of the member of The Shadow Council
to uh to work with the Sith Eternal and
snoke and and recruit using you know
making best car armor I guess at some
point in the future they are going to
lose their best guard Source because you
know Finn wasn't wearing best scar when
we find him in the first order
um but yeah I think that's still going
to continue I want thrawn to just be a
rogue I I want him to be a rogue and I
think and and all of that more of a
personal gripe with everyone I agree
fully and I think none of that is is
really going to conflict with how the
the first order is the big bad of the
sequel Trilogy you know this this nine
or so years after the battle of Yavin
time period that we're in right now with
the Mandalorian this is the prime time
just like the original thrawn appearance
in that Legends novel for thrawn to sort
of rise up before the 30 years later
rise of the first order and um yeah
another great moment too in this episode
is when they were talking about all
these allocating all these resources and
one of these members of The Shadow
Council wasn't I think it was hux wasn't
sharing their like Fleet or whatever
they're amassing with the rest of the
group and I'm like yeah there's there's
the explanation for the final order and
hexagonal having like a thousand Star
Destroyers I'm like you gotta start
somewhere and they're already building
that up so that we can get that big
reveal in episode nine so yeah it's like
you could have spared one of these
Superstar destroyers at some point no no
we needed to bury them all under the ice
events what's really cool when they rise
yeah so I think we'll be in an
interesting place with uh with the
Mandalorian people right I think it just
makes me sad to see that Mandalore is
just kind of this Wasteland and that
it's been Now co-opted by moff Gideon's
people right under their noses because
it's like okay well great they're never
really gonna have their Homeland again
and they need to let go of that I think
they just they seem to have something
great going on on Navarro some nice hot
springs they had some camps roasting
some kadus on bonfires like that seems
like a happy life just live there
forever you do not need to reclaim your
Homeland at that point I'm sorry it
sucks it's cursed we've said it before
we'll say it again Mandalore isn't a
place it's a people thank you Thor
Ragnarok that's correct I I hope that
someone says that or learns that that's
all I hope for maybe it'll be ig-12
himself through the voice of Taiko ytt
director of Thor Ragnarok
using yes and no as binary code to
communicate it yes yes no no yes yes yes
yes
um anyway well we'll leave it there for
this episode of WikiLeaks I know people
are gonna get mad at me for like being
too hard on this episode we're just
trying to figure it out because overall
I think Rick I mean we are doing a great
job shooting all this the action was
incredible yeah I mean the performances
were fun as always I liked the adventure
overall I just had questions overall
about the series and you know this
episode adds more questions to that list
I'm gonna still be trying to work
through them here on Wednesday mornings
uh but hey my Easter egg breakdown is
going to be coming tomorrow as always
you can follow me today boss follow
Hector at Hector is funny Tommy will be
back next week and we'll be back next
week to react to the season finale it's
gonna be an interesting one but you can
also check out the stuff I got going
over on the Deep dive we got an
investigation episode coming out on
Friday that's gonna look into the
history of post-credit scenes speaking
of post-credit scenes I think you'll
really enjoy that one you can follow new
Rockstar subscribe to WikiLeaks whatever
your podcast thank you for watching and
we
thank you
[Music]